It's like that with the Michael Shay, Michael Che with the SNL,
when they tried to, when he made the joke about Kanye west and it was all okay.
Everything was okay until he mentioned Caitlyn Jenner.
And then everyone went nuts about it.
Oh dude.
It's legitimately a good joke. When Michael Che was like, uh,
he was saying like, uh,
Kanye west is a white lady now because he's like into whatever
he was saying.
He was into fashion voting for Trump and he's like complaints about
whatever the the joke was. And he was like,
he turned into an old white lady and then it sort of picture of Caitlyn Jenner.
And it was like, by the way, I remember another, uh, guy who moved to,
um, Calabasas. And that was where the joke stopped. And it was like, okay,
Bruce Jenner turned into a old, old white lady as well. And that's a funny joke,
whatever, you know, whatever, not you think it's funny, it's a joke.
And there was this article dude that came out on,
was it indie wire? I don't want to get this wrong actually. What was it?
It was on, uh,
indie wa in the wire. Here it is. Yeah.
IndyWire Saturday night live Michael Che's Caitlin Jenner joke.
Wasn't funny. It was hate speech.
Uh, dude. Hey, are you all right? All right,
dude. Hate speech.
Imagine SNL doing hate speech.
You want to be a victim or what? Some people, they just want to be victims.
I swear to God.
Look at this over the week. This was so funny over the weekend,
starting at life head writer, Michael Che told a joke at the, by the way,
Michael Chase hilarious fan of Michael Che. Nice guy loved the dude,
told the joke at the expense of Caitlyn Jenner, uh,
that the joke totally bombed did not seem to bother headstrong comedian who
giggled along with cohost chuckle. And just by the way, uh,
there's another guy who's awesome. Colin Joe's is such a nice guy and hilarious.
Um, didn't really bomb the joke didn't bomb. Also.
Even if it did, who cares?
This is not the first time she has come under the scrutiny,
whatever that's because he's a talented community and any talented comedian
comes under scrutiny. Um,
cha uh,
straight male comedians using transgender people as a punchline bag for the
unfunny jokes. Chase so-called joke. I love this dude.
The writer calls it a so-called joke.
What do you know about jokes?
Who knows more about jokes?
You are Michael Che who knows more about Joe's.
You are the head writer SNL.
He said the singer was turning into an old white lady. He elaborated, I mean,
he used to be one of the coolest black dudes on board.
And now he's showing up at events and sweat pants, orthopedic sneakers,
and listening to Kenny J that was the joke is way funnier than what I said and
trying to get black people to light from funny.
How long before this guy named chase is named Kathy funny, taking on a joke.
The joke is fine. Even mildly funny. If Jay had stopped,
there would have been a perfect acceptable Quip that didn't necessarily even
reference trans people much less in a disrespectful way,
but she had to go and bring Caitlyn Jenner into it.
Now you think that I'm crazy. But about five years ago,
there was a fellow named Bruce Jenner and he moved to Calabasas. There you go.
That was the thing in one short sentence,
Che managed Shay manages to use the word fella,
the incorrect pronoun and Jenner's previous name. Okay.
But he was a guy, right? He misgenders her dead names,
her and actively calls her a word that is safe to assume she would never use to
describe herself. K as a refresher.
Sokak the writer as a refresher using a trans person's birth name is referred to
as dead naming and is considered.
An act.
Of violence.
Okay, dude, it's it's okay.
You know, you're going to be like
you're you're, that's not an act of violence. All right.
That's that's just somebody saying some as a joke on Sarah, not life.
That's not an act of violence.
And as a matter of fact is even
what's an act of violence is, is a threat, an act of violence.
Is somebody saying like, Hey, I'm going to you up. Is that an act of violence
or is an act of violence? Like striking someone? I don't know.
What do you think?
Even saying saying.
Something is not an act of violence. I mean,
it can incite an act of violence. Maybe
I don't see how it is. Maybe I'm wrong.
I'm a idiot when it comes to this and definitely talking out of my,
but holy. That made me laugh. When I read that part.
Like, if you want to be included, if you want to be,
if inclusion is real and you want to be accepted, then guess what, dude,
you get jokes, come in your way.
If you want to be included here, come the jokes.
Dude, make fun of me all day long.
A lot of these people, and this is not, this is,
this is the victims thing has gone out of control. Dude.
There are real victims out there that have been through real.
It's like, don't take, don't take that from them, man.
Um, it sucks, dude. Also that.
These articles,
no joke are what going to is these articles.
Are it's going to get Trump elected again.
That's what's going to get Trump elected again, a hundred percent.
The two things that Trump we're going to get,
there's going to get Trump elected again, and he's going to get elected again.
These are the two things that are going to get them elected again,
articles like that, tweets and like that.
And also the.
Horrible democratic choices.